all right
i think i am live
i'm going to do a start a slow start
here because
i want to make sure that uh that this
puppy is working
i am in sweden right now i don't like to
brag but i'm in my hotel room and we've
set up google hangouts i did some crazy
lighting things that i don't know if
they're legal
in this country but i did everything i
could to do with
lights and i moved the curtains and i
shifted chairs
and i actually have my computer on top
of an upside down
ice bucket and i'm gonna share
all my election thoughts i'm gonna make
some predictions because you know
that being in the prediction business is
always a good thing to do especially the
day before the election
i want to share some thoughts on all the
stuff that's going on back in the states
and give you guys a little bit of
insider
info on this tour that i'm on with
jordan peterson uh which has
just been absolutely unbelievable
uh so i'll really get going in about two
minutes or so i just want to do a little
slow start here
because i know when we send out these
live streams sometimes it takes a little
time to get to the feed and all that
so yeah so anyway so i am in
sweden right now uh we have a show
tonight it is now
it is 5 p.m in sweden on november 5th
right now our show is at seven o'clock
tonight so i'm going to do about an hour
a little bit more
than that right now with you guys i'm
going to do a q a so right now actually
we've been taking questions all day long
or all morning long depending on
where you are uh but if you go to
patreon.com
ruben you can submit a question and my
guys back in america
uh are taking the questions and then
they're sending them to me on my trusty
phone here we have a google doc
and uh google man is there anything they
don't do from spying on you to not
letting your videos go out to your
subscribers
plus google docs and allowing us to do
this um
okay so yeah it's five o'clock here in
sweden uh our show tonight is seven
o'clock i usually get there about a half
hour early i'm only about 10 minutes
away from the uh
the hotel uh this tour real quick let me
just do a little bit
on that um it's been absolutely amazing
as
of i think the show last night
um and last night we were in helsinki
finland
which i really think might have been the
best show we've done i mean we've
we've really been on a nice track with
these things jordan and i
are having a really nice groove at the
moment and i know when to poke fun with
him
and have some fun in the q a and some
nights he does some real
fire and brimstone stuff and some nights
it's a little looser some nights he
talks about all 12 rules some nights he
does the whole show
on one rule some nights i'm a little
sillier
uh suffice to say that last night was
the first night that we
actually slow danced on stage together
that's how the show ended so if you
haven't been to one of these shows
they're pretty much all sold out um but
if you haven't been and there's any
tickets in any of the remaining cities i
hope to see you guys there
i'm super excited to be there to be here
in sweden tonight actually because this
is one of the countries
that seems to be really affected by a
lot of the things that we talk about
relative to political correctness and
free speech and identity politics
and believe it or not sweden is our
fifth
most viewed country despite it being a
tiny country so our
our most viewed is the united states
then it's the uk then australia and
canada flip back and forth on three and
four and then five is sweden
which is really bizarre because there
aren't that many people here in sweden
um so yeah we've been to just in the
last 10 days or so we were in dublin
ireland we were in oslo norway we were
in helsinki finland
we've had a couple stops in the uk we'll
be in uh
copenhagen tomorrow in denmark uh we'll
be back in helsinki
we're going to be back in denmark i mean
it really is something else
and as of this morning it sounds like
we're just signing on for a whole bunch
more
uh next year starting in february it
looks like a whole bunch of stops in
australia it looks like we're gonna hit
up germany and france
and belgium and a couple other places
and uh
it's just really cool uh i also got some
really really great
uh career news which hopefully i'll be
able to announce in the next week or two
uh that i just found out a couple days
ago and it's sort of linked to all of
this stuff
um so i'm psyched on every front and you
know it's kind of funny
one of the things that i talk about when
i'm doing these shows at night and it's
usually the auditoriums the smallest one
we did was in amsterdam
a couple days ago we did a 900 seat
theater that is that's by far the
smallest most of them are 2 000 3000 or
so i think we did maybe one 5 000 in uk
uh early on in london um but i always
say to the audience at the beginning
that it's so bizarre because if you
spend any time online these days
especially on twitter it's like everyone
hates each other everyone's fighting
we're all going to our sides and
screaming at each other and everyone's
trying to own the libtards or the
conservatives or
all of that stuff and we all get caught
up in a little bit i get caught up in it
too sometimes and we're all
not our best selves all the time um
but then i go out to these shows at
night and i meet
thousands and thousands of great people
you know a couple protesters at some of
the events the the protesters in
amsterdam by the way they handed out
flyers i was very impressed like they
weren't screaming at people
they weren't you know stopping anybody
from getting in or shouting or anything
they actually just they printed out some
stuff and they handed it to people
i didn't agree with what they printed
out but i was like you guys are doing
protests right i actually gave them a
shout out
on stage because i was like this is this
is kind of right i also made fun of what
they wrote but
you know separate issue so anyway um
yeah the election
is tomorrow and uh well it's tomorrow
here i guess it's tomorrow for you guys
too right it's about eight a.m i think
los angeles time right now it's about 11
a.m east coast
so the big election is tomorrow so
there's a lot of thoughts that i want to
share with you and uh and
all right so here we go so first off i
want to be very
very clear about one thing if you are
watching tv today or you have been
watching the news for the past week or
reading all the think pieces or all of
that stuff
make it known to yourself and everyone
else that
nobody nobody has a freaking clue
what is going to happen tomorrow so all
the people pretending they know what's
up
and all the people who make all the
predictions and who are crunching all
the numbers
they don't know this is as big of a
crapshoot in american political history
as there
ever has been you know the analogy that
i've used from the beginning
is sort of that trump came in here and
tossed the chessboard up the pieces are
all over the place right now nobody has
an idea where those pieces are going to
shake out we can all take the best
estimated guesses we can all kind
we can perhaps look at polls and if
polling even works anymore and there's
some questions whether polls
traditionally politically work anymore
there's a lot of reason to think that
certain sets of people don't respond in
polls that they're using old landlines
in polls
that people for political reasons don't
want to talk to pollsters all sorts of
things
and you can even see you know it's
really interesting if you were to listen
to conventional wisdom for the last
let's say six or eight months
and you listen to mainstream media what
they've been saying is blue wave it's
all blue wave blue wave blue wave now
i said on live streams at least six
months ago
that that's not necessarily the way i
see it because i think people are so
sick of what the democratic party has
embraced which
is identity politics it's the
suppression olympics narrative
um it's that government is the answer to
everything
it's this democratic socialism or
socialist democratism
uh whatever you want to call it which
they'll drop the the democratic party as
soon as they're in power
i think people are really sick about
that but before i give you my
predictions
i just it's very important that everyone
understand like all the
experts are really not experts right now
they really aren't
and you can even see now in the last day
or two and i can even see this halfway
across the world
um that a lot of the predictors you know
and nate silver from 538 and the rest of
the people
everyone's kind of now going into 50 50
mode i saw some people on cnn before
suddenly everyone's going oh we thought
there was a blue wave but we just want
to be clear maybe not blue wave it's
like
everybody's guess is as good as anybody
else's um
but we can all use some contextual clues
to kind of figure out
what we think so here's what i'm gonna
do so first i'm gonna tell you what i
what i want to happen and some ways that
i think we can get out of this mess and
then i'll tell you
what i think will happen there's
probably no point in telling you what i
think will happen because if i'm wrong
it's like well ah see reuben doesn't
know what he's talking about and if i'm
right it's like okay zippity-doodah
um but i will i will tell you so look
here's what i what i think has to happen
you know before the election in 2016
with trump
um there weren't that many people that
thought trump could win and
all along the way you saw pundits on
every channel and youtubers and
everybody
it's never going to happen it's not real
blah blah blah and i was one of the
people i was on joe rogan's podcast the
day before the election
basically going i think the trump
thing's kind of real because
i was listening i was listening to
people and
i was seeing what the talk was online i
saw this incredible momentum
and even though it wasn't reflected in
the mainstream media i thought if
anything that gave it more reason to
think that it was real because they were
kind of ignoring it
so right now it's a little if you just
look at polls and you listen to what
mainstream media is talking about
it's almost impossible to garner what
what is happening i mean look
you could look at some of the polls
where almost every poll right now still
has
you know blue wave or democrats winning
and at the same time we're seeing these
massive
uh rallies that trump is doing that seem
as big
if not bigger than when he was doing
them two years ago
rally is not an answer of course and i
can tell you that that david
was voting yesterday in l.a and that the
uh that the lines he waited in line for
like three or four hours
so i think there will be certain pockets
that are blue that are going to vote
very heavily there'll be certain pockets
that are read
very heavily a couple things make um
[Music]
make midterms particularly difficult uh
one is it really really comes down to
turnout in a way
more than the main elections because at
least in presidential elections you're
gonna get that bar of
of who's gonna vote midterms you just
never know now it seems that there's
going to be high
turnout right and it seems like there's
been a lot of early voting and all that
kind of stuff
and it does seem that both sides are so
energized at the moment whether you're
fully in it
trump maga or you're a resister it seems
like you got a lot on the table right
now to get out there and vote
so i suspect and i think most people
would probably agree with this
that the turnout is going to be pretty
high um okay so here's what i think
here's what i sort of want to happen
right now
look if if you've been watching this
show you know the things that that i
care about most and you know
that for years now i have been talking
about why identity politics is so
dangerous that we will judge people on
their immutable characteristics
whether it's their skin color or their
sexuality or their gender of which there
are two
all of these things we will judge them
and then we will take from some we will
give to other we
others we will figure out who should get
into this school who should get this job
all of these things that are the
antithesis of the american dream
okay they are the reverse of everything
this country
was founded on was the country founded
perfectly no
has it made mistakes along the way yes
but by and large in the 200 plus years
of this nation
we have consistently bent more towards
equality
true equality which means that the laws
of the nation
are equal for everybody not that you are
going to be guaranteed success and some
people might be born with more some
might be born with less
some people will have more personal
drive some people will be lazy
some people will be given benefits from
family members some people won't
all of those things are real those those
are just the
that's just the sort of multitude of
options that exist in a free society
there is no guarantee of freedom but
this idea well there is not
freedom well there's no guarantee of
freedom but there is no guarantee of
success
all we can do is set up a system that
will hopefully give as many people the
opportunity
to pursue happiness to live lives that
are free based on their own
ideas that's what you want to do okay
i think now at this point as i do this
here on november 5th
2018 that the democratic party has in
no way at all taken a
moment to reject some of these bad ideas
i say this as someone that voted
democrat
my whole life i say that i think i've
said this before i think in mike
bloomberg's third term
when he flipped from a democrat to a
republican or something like that i
think i voted for him i'm not even
totally sure in new york city i'm
talking about as mayor
but i have voted democrat my whole life
i voted obama my whole life
you guys know my journey right i mean
the prageru video why i left the left
you know it's like i was one of these
people i worked at the young turks blah
blah blah
i still begrudgingly or or or self-uh
self-flagellatingly consider myself a
liberal
um but the left as it stands in america
today
which has now taken over the democratic
party and these democratic socialists
these these people are not liberal the
ideas that they are pushing that big
government is the answer
to everything these are not liberal
ideas
now look you guys know i like small
government stuff
and there's a great discussion to be had
about
what that means where is government
necessary where isn't it necessary i
love talking to libertarians i love
talking to and caps classical liberals
about about just that i love talking
about ideas
so it's like to talk about the minutia
of the day-to-day issues
actually isn't that interesting to me
but what i believe
is that the democrats have not stopped
you know when
before the trump election i kept saying
and i
i guess i was one of the few people
saying it on the left at the time and i
guess that's partly why
this show really took off but what i was
saying basically was
the left needs to stop doing it it needs
to stop playing identity politics it
needs to stop calling everyone racist
and bigot and homophobic and transphobic
and islamophobic and the rest of it
because all of your intellectual
opponents are not
evil they just aren't and i have not
seen any any reflection
across the board on the left what i have
seen is that there's some liberals
let's say some of my idw friends that
are liberals that
are basically on the outs of their party
and there's some big disagreement
within the idw now and i'm sure we'll do
shows about this on many of our channels
um about what to do right now because
i'm definitely on the side that the
democrats
they sort of need to be destroyed in
this election i don't mean just
beat but they really need to be
destroyed so
that liberalism if liberalism has a
chance
to come back out of the ashes of this
destroyed ideology which i and i think
it's a terrible ideology i think it is
i think identity politics which they
have embraced they have
absolutely embraced to the point that
you've got the democratic
um uh candidate for georgia governor
embracing linda sarsour bernie sanders
it's just crazy they've embraced it
they've taken it in
and i think that thing needs to be voted
out
and destroyed and if it's destroyed then
out of the ashes of that then i think
some true
liberalism some sensible voices in the
democratic party can come back
i don't know where they are now i mean
people keep saying to me well dave how
could you
how could you leave the democrats now
that doesn't mean i'm going to be a
republican and i'll talk about the
republicans and the conservatives in
just a second
but it's like i don't see anyone i i
don't see
anyone that represents any of the views
that i hold at this point where
is the jfk of the democrats
ask not what your country can do for you
ask what you can do for your country
that is the 180 to what bernie says
bernie wants to your government to give
you things it wants to tell
corporations how much they have to pay
you and it wants to give you free health
care which
and free education all these things
which are not free and free college for
everyone
at the same time while automation is
kicking in and we're gonna have less
need for people to go to college and all
of these things
they all sound good it all sounds good
diversity and equality
it all it's all buzz words that all
sound great but it's me
it's not only meaningless it's much more
dangerous than meaningless it's actually
it's actually perverse and it's actually
antithetical to freedom
so what i think is well it gets the
predictions in a sec what i think has to
happen
the best way out of this right now if
you want to get out of this political
mess that we seem to be in
at the moment i think if the democrats
basically got destroyed so that
a strong signal if the trump signal in
2016 was not good enough
a strong signal would be sent to them
that the bulk of the country
is against this hysterical
mob nonsense then maybe finally
the liberals would stand up they would
say you know what
we've we've been held hostage by our own
side and we're not going to do it
anymore
and then they could start rebuilding a
healthy party and i want to be clear
about saying this is saying that
uh jordan peterson talks about often in
these talks that we're doing
you know if you're in a fight let's say
you're in a fight with your uh with your
spouse
you don't want to beat your spouse i
don't mean physically although you don't
want to do that
you don't want to beat them in a fight
to the point that they're the loser
because then you're just married to a
loser
okay i think this is a good analogy for
this i want these guys to be beat
so that then a hand can be put out for
them so that they can
kind of come back they can kind of find
look through the ashes and go whoa we
lost our way
let's abandon some of these bad ideas
let's return to true liberalism
true tolerance live and let live where
perhaps we want a little more government
perhaps we want a little less
to go to the military perhaps uh we
still want to fight for the social
issues we still
generally are pro-choice but we we don't
think that all the people who are
pro-life
hate women i mean some semblance
of liberal tolerance that used to exist
that in effect is gone these days
i think that can come back but the only
way it can come back is if this thing
gets destroyed
so look at it the other way let's say
the democrats do well
so now where are we at if the democrats
you know take the house and the senate
well now
i even hate to say this but it seems
like we'd be
in like this low-grade cold war
slash civil war where they're gonna have
to try to impeach trump
and then and it's like we already saw
what everything
everything that happened with kavanaugh
and it's like due process won't matter
it will just be
the it will be a mob verse verse
whatever you want to call trump at this
point and that will not be good for the
country if you think it's bad now we
will look back and think that these were
the good old days
so if they win they will be emboldened
the last few liberals whoever they are
they email me every now and again
shell-shocked with ptsd they can't
figure out what's going on anymore the
last few liberals will be purged because
that's what the left has done the left
has purged
basically all of their free thinkers i
think you know of enough interviews that
i've done
to understand why this is because they
have a narrower and narrower
accepted range of thought
so you can't i mean show me a democrat
where are the blue dog democrats show me
a democrat these days that's pro-life
it does it's not that important to parse
every little issue like this
but it's like show me where where is a
democrat who
uh who will talk about smaller
government and states rights and some of
these things these used to not just be
conservative principles right
so i think this thing needs to be
destroyed and if it's destroyed
then they could possibly come back and
then what they would do is as a sensible
as a sensible left
whether i'd be part of them or not as a
sensible left
i think then they could potentially
moderate the parts of the right that
maybe people are worried about
okay so so that's what i think would be
the best situation so they get basically
they get destroyed and by the way
if if that happened so i know a lot of
people will be watching this and
thinking okay well if the democrats get
destroyed
now trump's got that you know he's got
the house in the senate he's he's
already a year into his presidency or
you know two years into his presidency
one tournament to the presidency
and now isn't he just going to be
unhinged and do whatever he wants to do
trump as a populist i still think this
even now
wants to be popular and you'd have to
show me
look you got to put the tweets aside for
a moment when you're talking about trump
we can talk about them
perhaps in another live stream but in
terms of the policy that he's done
two years later i don't think any of the
people that voted for him
are that upset about policy their taxes
are lower we don't seem to be going into
any other wars we've
reconfigured some trade deals that seem
to be making some sense
the economy is doing pretty well um
etcetera etcetera
so i don't think any of the core trump
people um
are have looked and gone you know what i
voted for trump but now i think this
identity politics left makes sense like
there's got to be somebody out there
like that but i don't think there's many
but you know another thing is look on
the left right now
you've got you've got the the far
leftists
the democratic socialists whatever they
are and then you've got the couple
liberals that are trying to figure out
who they are and where they are and
where they should be
and that's it that that really is it
maybe you've got some further left green
party people or something like that but
in terms of what the discussion is on
the left it's either you buy identity
politics you buy
that the america's an evil patriarchy
and all of those things or you're pretty
much on the outs i'm being slightly
hyperbolic here obviously
uh on the right though i do see
intellectual diversity you've got the
trump wing
you've got the anti-trump never trump
people you've got this new wing of
libertarians and i'd say classical
liberals that are kind of going
all right we can play ball here we seem
to be able to have conversations with
these people
um so even if we're not one of them
necessarily or even if we don't consider
ourselves conservative per se
at least there we can talk to these
people uh i can tell you that
for me i go to i go to college events
and i go to these events with jordan and
i go to also and i do stand up and all
these things
and i talk about often to conservative
crowds relatively conservative crowds
let's say
um and i talk about being gay married
pro-choice against the death penalty for
legalizing marijuana
uh for euthanasia for reforming the
prison system all these things and
people seem to dig it
even if they disagree they want to have
that conversation so i see
you got the trumps you got the never
trumps you got the libertarians
classical liberals
um and then you probably have some other
then i guess you probably have some
some more neocons but maybe that's the
the never trumpers
but basically you've got a couple wings
that are kind of battling it out right
now
now does trump take most of the oxygen
in that space of course he does
absolutely um but
at least there's some level of healthy
debate there um and i think those people
are malleable you know when i go to
uh i spoke at the turning point usa
um young leadership summit it was the i
think they said it was the largest
gathering
of young conservatives in american
history i spoke there uh peter thiel
spoke there seb gorkas book there
um a whole slew of uh steve scalise
spoke there
candace owens and charlie kirk and a
whole bunch of others and what i found
was young conservatives really are
open-minded the portion
of the right that really perhaps was
close-minded or really was against gay
marriage or really
um was against some of the social stuff
i think that portion of the religious
right say the mike huckabee wing
i i don't think they have as much
influence anymore and i think
that partly it's because some of us in
the online space have been
somewhat effective communicating that
for conservatives if you guys want to
live your
lives however you want to live them you
got to let other people live their lives
however they want to live them in this
case say gay people or people that want
to
smoke pot or whatever the hell it is
somebody wants to do so i'm
really enthused by the fact that i see a
libertarian strain
in the republican party look you know
i've done a couple videos with ben
shapiro on the gay marriage issue and i
don't like talking about it anymore
because the ship has sailed gay marriage
is here
and they're not going to suddenly force
a zillion gay people to get divorced
you know they don't like divorce either
okay um but
when i hear someone like ben shapiro who
wasn't he wasn't like
screaming get the government out of
marriage before gay marriage right
but once it was passed by the supreme
court ben takes the libertarian position
on it that the government shouldn't be
involved i hear dennis prager take the
libertarian position
i hear most of these guys take that
position now that's
that's just fine however you got to get
to the right and conclusion that will
maximize freedom for the most amount of
people
i think that's the best thing possible
so i see some hope there and i know i'm
i'm on the outs of what many of my uh my
friends
and and some of my id w crew think about
this
um but that but first off that's healthy
and we're happy to talk about it so
that's that's most important
um but i think the democrats have to be
destroyed
and out of that destruction maybe
something good comes out of it and they
they reconfigure they figure out oh
we're going to return to our roots where
are our daniel patrick moynihan's
where are our jfks where are the blue
dog democrats
and then because of their moderation
right because then
they'll have taken their party from the
far left they'll have brought them in a
little bit
i think what can happen on the right and
i'm seeing this i'm
i just i'm seeing it i'm seeing it every
night when i go out and i give these
talks literally all over the world now
but i'll do it from american context
for the purposes of this it's like i go
out there
and i see tolerance amongst
conservatives it's not what you will see
on cnn where
you know don lemon's going to tell you
that that all white men are evil
terrorists or whatever the hell he said
it's like you're not going to see that
um but i'm seeing it for real and that's
why that's why i'm enthused i'm enthused
generally right now because
uh i live in two different worlds i live
in the twitter world and as i said then
i live in
the real world where i'm meeting all
sorts of great people doing all sorts of
things
so i think there's a chance that that
through all of this
will see a resurrection uh of the
democrats
if they get destroyed and i think at the
same time that could cause
an emboldening an emboldenment of the of
the decent conservatives of which i
think there are many now
so that they will push out the bad
voices in their party so for the real
the race realists or the white
supremacists or the real
far right people who want america to be
a white ethno state
which is completely against uh the
founding documents and that everything
that america
is and is not conservative by any
stretch of the imagination
if anything oddly that's more left if
you really think about it because that's
about big government making
decisions about people if you want
people to truly be free which if freedom
ultimate freedom is on the right um i
don't see how that even makes sense but
that's a that's a whole other topic
um how sort of race got caught up
between the right left dichotomy
and as i always say it's like this is
not even about right left anymore
you're either for state power or you're
for personal freedom
if you believe in the individual then
look then look down the
look down the line look at all of the
candidates you've got there and which
ones
and which party do you think will give
you
more power to control your life that
will allow you
to control more of your money you to
figure out how you want to live and
where you want to live
and not take from you or give to you and
take from someone else or any of those
things and
generally that happens to be the
republicans right now
and i say this as again i am not a
republican
uh okay so let's uh let's make a couple
of predictions or should i do a couple
questions here
hey guys give me uh for my guys i'm
talking to you guys right now throw me
like two or three good questions right
at the top of my document here
uh and i'll jump on those first um
oh by the way guys real quick um if
you're in the la area
i'm at the uh the brea improv on
november 13th
and and on four
on the 14th i'm at oxnard at levity live
and i will be with an idw member doing
stand up so i do about an hour of stand
up
and then i bring on one of the idw
people we did this with jordan peterson
as a surprise guest sold
sold out uh salt lake city a couple
weeks ago it was great
i crushed it for like an hour and then i
brought out peterson and and we just
laughed and told jokes for like another
45 minutes or hour or so
by the way guys also if you want to jump
in on the questions that i'm going to be
doing right now
um you can go to patreon.com ruben
report and we're doing all sorts of
interesting things with patreon these
days it's called ruben select
and we've got a members-only feed where
people are having actual decent
conversation very different
often than the youtube comments section
or twitter and things of that nature
okay so what the hell am i doing here
quick reset
uh i'm talking election i'm live in
sweden right now i've got a show in
about an hour and a half with jordan
peterson
and uh i'm telling you my thoughts on uh
on what i think
will happen and or what i think should
happen to kind of give us an
out i've already given you that right
it's sort of just the destruction of the
democrats so that they finally start
waking up again that was what
i was asking for before trump was ever
elected guys
guess what's going to happen trump's
going to get elected if if the democrats
don't run from this identity politics
stuff and run from calling everybody
racists and bigots but they haven't
they've just doubled down doubled down
double down double down and one of the
reasons you're probably watching this
and you're probably into what the idw is
doing is because we're
some of the few people that are willing
to talk about it mostly
as as former lefties i mean if you look
at
the idw crew if you look at eric and
brett
and sam and me and even
christina and joe rogan most of these
people were for
they're either lefties now if you can
accept that that's still part of the
left or they're at least
former lefties you know there's only
really the ones that i would say are
traditionally conservative really
shapiro is probably the only one so it's
so funny people
will paint us as if we're all these
right-wing maniacs as the guardian tried
to do this week
and it's like no but but the more
that you write articles like that the
more that you make it clear
that nobody that has a free thought is
allowed to be part of the left well then
you're making the right the biggest tent
ever and i that's another thing that i
think is happening right now
and that's why i said there's these
different columns on the right that are
acceptable
and that are having healthy dialogue and
they're it's just not happening the
other way okay
so here we go let me let me knock out
one or two questions and then
uh and then i'll jump into some actual
predictions
um dave politicians keep throwing around
the term blue wave without defining it
defining it in your opinion what type of
election results would constitute a wave
um well i'm going to get to my
predictions in a minute so let me let me
hold that one for uh
for just a sec um i love this question
if you
were famous in a field disconnected from
politics
would you speak out on political issues
or would you stay out of it
so this is tough so one of the questions
we get most at these jordan peterson
events and when i
do the stand-up events and whatever else
is people that are kind of afraid to say
what they think and often we get this at
colleges where kids are afraid to say
what they think to their professors
because they don't want their grades to
be hurt
but we get this all the time from people
that are afraid to say that you know i'm
for low taxes and people are gonna say
you're racist and then you're gonna get
fired or something like that or you'll
be on the outs at your job
now that's that's not for a famous
person that's just for the day-to-day
person and that's that's most of us
right
so so that's pretty freaking scary that
that there is a huge amount of people in
the west
walking around afraid to say what they
think that's why years ago i was saying
this thing about i'm not afraid
right now and i still stand by this i
said this about two years ago
i am not afraid of the government coming
from my free speech right now i am
afraid that the masses are actively
silencing themselves and then what
happens
when you have a massive group of people
that this little chihuahua i think as
eric weinstein is called the chihuahua
effect you've got this little mass of
people
that are yelping and screaming like a
chihuahua that's just really loud
it seems much bigger than it is and then
it has infected the media and it's
infected academia and the rest of it but
it's i really still believe this it's
not that many people that believe
that stuff it just has figured out a way
to just permeate through the system in
the worst possible ways
and if enough of us would just stand up
and look at the chihuahua
just stare at that freaking chihuahua i
think the chihuahua would go running and
i think that that's what we've got to do
here
that's sort of the metaphor for it but
what you got to do is go out and vote
and say no more chihuahua
not going to find it actually i think it
was the atlantic that published a study
a poll maybe three weeks ago or so that
basically
only eight percent of people in america
really are on board all of this
political correctness
social justice stuff so if that's true
we should not be afraid of them and many
of them by the way they're
self-owning hostages they're their own
hostages because they've used those
tactics i see this all the time
if you're one of these people that has
used the tactics of calling everyone you
know a bigot and a racist
everyone that you disagree with is a
bigot well first off this is why peter
bogosian calls it a secular religion
it's so
morally empowering how incredible is
that
you're saving the world because you're
fighting bigots you're fighting nazis
and you can punch nazis can't you
this is a huge problem it inflates your
ego it inflates your your
sense of self-importance and it makes it
like you're on a religious mission these
are the very same people who hate
religion
so i think most people are not for that
i would say by and large
80 percent of people just want to live
and let live now within that eighty
percent you're going to have some that
are going to lean conservative and
maybe are i mean abortion i just think
is an easy one to discuss in this matter
let's say they're pro-life but they want
to basically live and let live
and then you've got uh within that 80
percent democrats or people on the left
who are uh pro-choice
and but basically they want to live in
the same society and they don't want the
government coming in and telling
everyone how to live and all of that
and they don't want open borders you
know i love the open borders one it's
like man
the same people who all day long will
tell you what an evil racist patriarchy
america is what do they also want
open borders because apparently they
want everyone to share in the horror
that is america
you know nobody ever leaves i say this
all the time right it's like nobody ever
leaves
lena dunham she's still here she's still
here i'm sure she could have a lot of
people that would help her leave
but she's still here because everyone
knows at the end of the day at the end
of
all of the arguments tell me how
horrible and evil and racist america is
tell me all of these deeply ridiculous
things not to say we're perfect but tell
me again and again and again
how evil we are and the patriarchy and
all of this stuff
and at the end everyone wants to come to
america
and nobody wants to leave and that tells
you something so the next time they tell
you this is like nazi germany you know
what nazi germany didn't let citizens
leave nazi germany put its own citizens
in concentration camps people weren't
dying to get in
to nazi germany they were dying to get
out of nazi germany
so also the superlatives and the
hyperbole that they use
is really uh is really terrible so an
answer to your question
for famous people so this is someone
like an actor let's say or an athlete or
whatever i mean i can tell you this
so mark ruffalo is a big lefty activist
and mark ruffalo for those of you that
don't know he is
he plays the hulk in the avengers movies
um
i followed him on twitter for a while
and he just he's all about identity
politics i mean all the things that i
that i don't like he's entitled to his
views but like
it was just like this endless stream of
all of this stuff that i don't like to
the point that i was just like i just
don't like this guy anymore i don't like
him and i unfollowed him
but then when i was watching and then i
hadn't thought about him for i don't
know six or eight months or something
and then as i was watching avengers
infinity war which was
fan freaking tastic by the way um
every time he would pop up on screen i
could see the man mark ruffalo and not
bruce banner or the hulk
i could just i was just like oh you've
brought politics into this
nobody wants to think about politics
when you're watching the avengers
and you guys have done that so so look
you should use your voice however you
see fit
and colin kaepernick who i basically
disagree
uh with on on the bigger issues he's
welcome to do what he wants
the owners are welcome to do what they
want trump is welcome to do what
what he wants the media is welcome to
critique and back whoever they want
and that whole thing as i've said many
times was an exercise in freedom
everyone said what they wanted and
nobody got fired for it
everyone everyone made the decision
accordingly it was an
exercise in freedom and freedom's a
little sloppy and sometimes it may not
feel that great at the end
because that's what freedom is it's it's
the experiment it's the experiment of
life
and the best thing you can do out of
that experiment if you want to get
something better after is give as much
opportunity for freedom to take root
um so as for as for public people
it's on them to decide what to do but i
see this i have friends i mean good
friends who are
who are in hollywood who who are big
lefties that you know
tweeting and doing all this stuff and
i'm like
could you just not it's also it's sort
of like
just because you're an actor it doesn't
mean people care what you think
and if anything i think at this point
there may be getting more people to vote
against the things that they're pushing
than than
the other way around but i would say
ultimately it's on everyone to figure
that out
um okay one more and then i'll jump in
and on a couple other things
um
[Music]
this is a great one why is a candidate
who vows to support and follow the
constitution such a hard sell to
americans
so i actually think that it isn't a hard
sell but it has been framed as a hard
sell because of the media
because basically if you if you are a
constitutionalist so the closest we have
to that i'd say there's a couple
so you've got say rand paul who is the
most libertarian member of the senate
you've got ted cruz he's pretty close to
a constitutional conservative
uh you've got uh mike lee you know
couple others you got justin amash up in
uh in michigan you got you got a couple
that are a little more libertarian
meaning they believe in states rights
they believe in due process they believe
in the constitution and letting states
do as much as possible and
and all that now i think most people are
for that
but for some reason there's something
about
the cult of personality about the
presidency
that makes us it's almost like we want a
king
and you know in europe they often have
prime minister who's in effect the
president the one that's the head of the
government and then you've got
the president it's a little bit
different in every country but the
president is often
sort of a figurehead that can go uh have
the dinners
and meet the entrepreneurs and do and
travel to other countries and do all the
niceties and in a weird way
it's almost like we're starting to need
that in america
because trump is now both he's the
president who has to get [ __ ] done and
he's also the all-encompassing
personality
all the time now that's also a little
specific to who trump is and how he
operates
um but i would say
most people if they really understood
what the constitution lays out the
constitution is
the most perfect document
in modern history and it was only
written a couple hundred years ago
it guarantees the most freedom for the
most people it was
i say this all the time guys it was
written by
imperfect men some of whom who owned
slaves who later then were writing the
laws to free the slaves
and we can look back and and use our
2018
judgments on all of the people of the
past and guess what
history will not be kind on you either
because if you eat meat right now in 40
years
when they've figured out all the ways to
scientifically engineer meat
and there are pictures of you with a
freaking rib eye bone in your mouth
eating meat
and your grandchildren who will have
been indoctrinated into all of this
look at you and think you're disgusting
and you just have to die
and you're old and look what you did to
the environment it's like this
this is real this is the repeating of
history this is how generations move on
and on and on
and we've got to put an end to this so i
think most people do
actually want to live by the
constitution i think if most people
really understood what limited
government is
if most people really understood that
you should be involved more in your
local politics
than in uh national politics that
if you don't like if florida's education
system is bad then move elsewhere
they've got low taxes though so you
might have to pay more taxes elsewhere
if you care really care about uh
legalizing marijuana you can move to cal
colorado if you don't like how lefty
california is becoming
and the incredibly high taxes things
that i'm not thrilled with right
um then then leave california and and
maybe go to arizona
what an incredible experiment you have
here that doesn't mean it's easy it
doesn't mean it's right
oh no not right because i do think it is
right it doesn't mean it's easy it means
it's on
you to figure out a place to live in a
community to be part of and all of those
things and you have an opportunity to do
it here
because if the federal government
controls everything you got to leave the
freaking country and and if you want a
little bit more on this just so that i'm
not repeating myself
uh check out my interview from about two
years ago with randy barnett who's a
constitutional law professor
at georgetown he's argued in front of
the supreme court um
he talks about the football it's one of
the real conversations that i had that
affected me the most in terms of why
small government and
and constitutional principles is uh is
important okay let me uh
let me jump over here uh guys by the way
the uh the link
for the stand-up gigs november 13th and
14th in brea and in oxnard which are
outside of la
is in the uh description right down
below
um okay i've got to get some more
questions people are getting people are
giving me questions and i got to get to
them
from your recent travels do you have an
impression of how europe and scandinavia
are handling these issues of identity
politics and freedom of speech or more
specifically if
their left feels different from that of
the states in a significant way now look
it's a little bit
the type of people who are coming to an
event where jordan peterson and i
are speaking um obviously are a
self-selected group so i'm talking to
people who are very sensitive to these
issues who are concerned
about the direction of their country
they're worried about free speech
they're worried about identity politics
you know here in the in the nordic
countries that we've been in now oslo
uh and and here in sweden this is the
particularly interesting one because as
i said we have a lot of viewers
in sweden and it does seem like there's
something a little more precarious
happening in sweden at the moment i'm
going to talk about it on stage tonight
and we'll see we'll see um you know
people will always
the left often will say oh look at the
nordic countries look at these socialist
nordic countries
and it's like you know these countries
are pretty much all
white and i know you don't like that and
they have a
shared culture and they have a shared um
history
and that actually isn't what america is
we
are the great melting pot and there is a
difference when you have people that all
come from one area and all have a shared
history and a shared culture
that just is that has nothing to do with
racism or anything like that
but at the same time i think these
countries are all having their own
struggles because as
the uh as the immigration numbers have
changed and things like that and
integrating people
i think things have gotten a little bit
weird and i think this is happening
across europe you can watch doug uh read
douglas
murray's great book the strange death of
europe and and germany's struggling with
this after letting in a million
plus refugees and then how much can you
give to people and then it's hard to get
them off the dole and how do you
integrate them
and and all of that almost has nothing
to do with religion even so don't make
this about religion even
um so it's a little hard to say i think
i'll have a better sense
we're doing a second show in oslo in a
couple days and we'll be back here in in
sweden in a couple days too
i can tell you from the people i'm
meeting there is a definite concern
about it
and what a lot of them i think have said
to me is that they're worried that the
culture war that seems to be
being fought so hard in america right
now is starting to leak into these
countries
but that's what the internet is right
like we're all talking about the same
things i can tell you one of the most
inspiring things
it's inspiring and kind of dangerous i
guess at the same time or a little scary
is that i'm speaking to people all over
the world right now and it's
really cool like last night so at these
q a's that i do
um so people can buy an extra ticket
jordan does a
separate meet and greet after and then i
do a meet and greet and jordan usually
gets about 100 people or so or maybe
more than that
and mine's usually smaller like 20 or so
people it's all good it's
jordan's show i'm not jordan it's no
problem um but because i have a smaller
group i can jordan really you know he
could take a picture with you he can say
hi real quick but they got to kind of
keep it moving on
although people are thrilled to do it
and it's wonderful for mine usually we
do we go into my green room or
a side room or a cafeteria and i get 20
or 30 people
uh sometimes less sometimes more and we
all kind of sit around and we and we
chat about things and we really get
one-on-one time and i get to meet a lot
of these people and hear their concerns
and what they're talking about
and it's like last night when we were in
um
where the hell was i last night was oh
we were in uh in helsinki
uh i chatted with a couple uh finnish
people there was a girl
and a guy there from estonia and she was
talking about the exact same things that
the finnish people were talking about
there was a guy
that was originally from mexico who
moved to finland and he was talking
about the same things
it's like this stuff really does
transcend borders and
i'm meeting people that are that are
black and white and gay and straight and
trans people showing up to peterson
shows and everything
and and people want to fight this
identity politics thing i think
a huge growing number of people see it
and that that sort of brings us all the
way back to the beginning about why i
think
the democrat party the democratic party
in america
sort of has to be it has to be hollowed
out and rebuilt and i and i hope that is
uh what will happen all right let's see
are you concerned about the response of
the left if they don't gain power
in the us tomorrow yeah i mean again
this is why
calling your opponents racist and nazis
and claiming that everyone's a white
supremacist
this is why it's so dangerous there's no
way to walk that back
it's possible like i just have
fundamental differences
with the people that i'm talking about
here right i have differences of
political opinion
i don't think they're evil i think there
are some evil people pulling the strings
that
that some of the leadership was really
bad people who just want power
but i think by and large the road is the
road to hell is paved with good
intentions and i don't think most of
these people are evil but dennis prager
has a great line on this he says the
right thinks that the left is wrong
the left thinks that the right is evil
and i think that that's pretty spot on
here they
if you believe that everyone you're
arguing against is a nazi well then
you're never going to concede and this
was also the danger
from beat one if you were going to keep
calling trump hitler which actually is
the
it for this people that hate cultural
appropriation this is the height of
cultural appropriation taking a man
who committed a mass genocide caused
i mean six million jews 20 million
russians war
world war et cetera et cetera it's like
you've just appropriated the deaths of
an awful lot of people
to to put it on to put it on trump for
all the flaws that
this man might have um but once you
label somebody these horrible things
it's almost impossible to walk it back
so let's say they get destroyed tomorrow
the left gets destroyed right the
democrats get destroyed what what would
be
sensible would be a moment of reflection
maybe we screwed up here
maybe we have gone a little bit off the
deep end maybe maybe
the american people are realizing that
it can't just be the way we want it it
can't just be big government
and bernie and elizabeth warren because
we want it
um that what we really want is smaller
government that way a guy like trump
if we really think he's the devil can't
have too much power that would be a
sensible
reevaluation is there any evidence that
that will happen
i no i mean there isn't like i'm telling
you what i think
is the is the is the tiniest possibility
here to get us out of this mess
is that the party gets resurrected that
that then
trump then feels like he has a bit of a
mandate
he then pull he can then say to whoever
you think is on the right
you know these these really bad guys i
don't need you get out of my way
and and he can govern perhaps a little
bit more from the center which
sort of is what i think he's doing at
the moment anyway but for the people
that wanted to take a stronger hit
on the on the people on the far right
perhaps he could do that
um and also you know i i don't think the
country or
i don't think any movement can exist on
anger
and resentment and outrage all the time
so
who knows maybe after a couple years if
if the democrats really got beat trump
maybe would be like you know what i did
it in one term and now there would be an
opportunity for a decent conservative
say a nikki haley or somebody like that
uh that
would run on something very different
than trump because the country wouldn't
want
outrage it wouldn't want trolling it
wouldn't want the battle between the
media
and and the presidency anymore so and
trump would just say all right i did one
i won
i'm gonna walk away a winner here's
somebody else i mean it sort of sounds
like the apprentice doesn't it like i
think anything is possible these days
but we gotta start thinking we need to
start building a better story
so that the story we so everyone's just
thinking of a story that all ends
horribly but we need to start putting
out some stories that end well and i
think that that could potentially be one
of them
um what's your biggest aha moment while
being on tour with jordan
uh have any of your views change or
evolve well first off
it really this has been an honor that i
can't even fully explain like jordan
is the leading public intellectual in
the world i think he is the most
uh influential and clearest thinker
that we have possibly
really in the world i mean i i just
don't know another at least certainly
someone that's speaking english
um this tour has been absolutely amazing
there has not been a moment
that has has gone awry or wrong uh the
worst thing that happened was one
in one city i can't even remember where
it was maybe in
in miami i said we were in fort
lauderdale or something like that like
like it's just been great uh being
around him
is kind of intoxicating i've really
tried to incorporate the 12 rules into
my life i'm not perfect but i'm trying
to be as you can see i'm sitting up
straight i think my shirt fits right i'm
not lying and all sorts of other stuff i
pet a cat if i see it
even though i'm allergic um i would say
you know his debate between the debate
that he had between him and sam
about meaning and where does value come
from
and that to give you the very very short
version that sam believes
that meaning can come from facts alone
although he does believe in the value of
stories but jordan believes that facts
alone can't give
value and that you need these stories
and that he would argue that the
stories of religion of christianity have
given
a um well he would say the old testament
and the new testament
have given a have unlocked
an ancient truth let's say a timeless
truth
um he has kind of moved me on that it's
pretty powerful stuff when i hear him
uh go through it every night and he
really does i mean i'm telling you guys
90 some odd shows i've been around for
about 70 of them
and he challenges himself every night i
haven't seen him do the same show twice
and i also can tell you this this guy is
not an actor he is exactly the same
off stage off camera or whatever it is
that he is otherwise we've eaten a lot
of steaks together we've had a lot of
great conversations
and uh and i'm honored i'm really i'm
honored to be part of this thing and
hopefully we're going to keep continuing
it and
and some other cool stuff is uh going on
uh how's the response to jordan and you
different
in europe and the us i mean one thing
although although last night in helsinki
was a little different the european
crowds are a little more tame
so when i've gone up usually so the show
starts they announce me
you know host the room before dave room
in america the crowds have virtually all
they go completely bananas sometimes
i get standing ovations before i even do
anything i mean it really it's like
i'm like holy cow i cannot believe this
um
and then you know there i like to play
with the crowd so there'll be some
heckling and some screaming and i get
people to kind of yell and have fun or
whatever i do my thing for 10 or 15
minutes
jordan then does his thing for about an
hour and a half or so as i said
different every single night
and then and then we do a moderated q a
the two of us for about 40 or 45 minutes
the crowds in in europe generally have
been a little bit more
subdued some of the countries it's
english isn't their first language but i
don't think that's nearly it i think
there's a certain
uh there's just a different feeling
about sort of what theater or what live
performance is
but last night in helsinki was was i
think it might have been our best show i
mean it was
phenomenal phenomenal um
so it's a it's a little bit different
i think maybe we've both been a little
less
political the shows actually haven't
been very political since we've been in
europe
uh jordan's going more to the to the
biblical stuff and sort of
the more direct uh responsibility of the
individual stuff
so that i would say that's been one
thing all right guys we're gonna go a
little bit longer and then i have to
meet that jordan peterson fellow we are
in
uh denmark sweden tonight we're back in
denmark next week
tomorrow i'm sorry we're in we're in
sweden
tonight uh then we're in denmark
tomorrow we're back
in sweden next week we're back in oslo
next week et cetera et cetera all right
let me just jump in on a couple super
chats cause i see a whole bunch of you
uh jumping in here um hey dave love your
work thoughts on candace owens blexit
and its effects on identity politics
calling it now calling it now jewish
exit jegs it
i mean look i think a lot of minorities
are realizing you don't have to vote for
the democrats just because you're a
minority if you're
asian and you realize now that identity
politics is working
against you harvard is taking less
asians because they don't want too many
asians because asians
test too well you might realize this is
a bad idea that has
been embraced by the democrats um
[Music]
so i think i think also jewish people
suffer from this because
jews by and large put a tremendous
amount into education and into family
and because of that they have succeeded
and because of success you're no longer
thought of as a victim and nobody wants
to be a victim
but because of that then to the
standards of the oppression olympics
you're now a bad guy
so it's like you know which is why when
this pittsburgh thing happened which was
absolutely horrific obviously
it's like then suddenly the left's all
about the jews but it's like
you kind of like people that are victims
and i'd rather be alive
and hated than dead and liked just
that's just me though
i'm 16 and i realize how outnumbered i
am as a libertarian conservative
should the voting age be lowered i don't
think the voting age should be lowered
right now i think there's just too much
confusion related to the internet and
everything else i should do a little bit
more on this let me get an
expert in to come and talk about that um
dave nice show some of the best stuff on
youtube quick question do you think
we're in the middle of a political
realignment
a massive one i mean i this is what i'm
saying about how these ideas are
spreading across the world i think the
west is grappling
with what freedom is i think this is
happening across
borders i think people are waking up i
mean again how cool is it that
a young girl who i met in estonia last
night is sitting across from a mexican
immigrant to finland
with an american youtuber listening to a
canadian
psychologist it's awesome
it's incredibly inspiring don't you know
we all watch
you guys are right now right now you
person watching this you're most likely
watching on this thing or on your
computer right
and chances are you're alone right now
or maybe you're listening to it
and it's like you're probably alone and
it makes you think you're the only one
thinking these things
but don't think that joe rogan's podcast
is crushing it our audio podcast has now
superseded our youtube views whether
youtube is unsubscribing people are not
letting
videos go out to the feed or whatever
are we're doing better on the audio
podcast side
at this point so it's a it's a lonely
thing
podcasting and all this stuff because
you don't know how many other people are
into it but i believe
way more are into it and that's also why
they keep
calling us all bigots and racists and
all of those other things because
they're losing control of the narrative
dominic read this out loud and make my
day ha ha i did it okay
um is the idw going to suggest specific
legislation to fix
issues that's a really interesting idea
what i can tell you is we're trying to
figure out
what the future of the idw is you know
are we just about having conversations
or is there a political future maybe
some people are going to run
not me i would run from politics but if
shapiro wants to be president maybe i'll
be press secretary for like the most
ridiculously scandalous week ever
um you know are we a are we a youtube
replacement are we a touring company
are we a publishing house i mean who
knows are we all of these things i think
we're having all of these discussions
they're ongoing you know some of us
have different wants and needs than
others so we're trying to figure that
all out
um dave are you at the meet and greet
tonight as well as jordan i have a
little gift
to give you that i think you'll find
funny would be nice to hand it over in
person thanks so i do a different
meet and greet than jordan does um but
if you
go to the omg vip website just search
omg vip dave rubin
you should be able to get tickets to my
meet and greet if they closed it already
because it's so close to show time
uh the name of the tour manager is john
just hand john what you want to give to
me and
hopefully it's not ricin or something
like that uh welcome to sweden mr rubin
um okay i'm sorry i'm not getting to as
many questions as i would have liked to
here okay so all right so wait so it's
time for predictions because i only got
like two or three minutes left
so look i said a year ago i don't think
this blue wave is gonna happen
uh i just see too much too much exposure
of these bad ideas to really believe
that and the media can't quite get it
which shows you how archaic they are
so i'm gonna make some predictions now
again how did i start this thing an hour
ago
the prediction business is a bad
business and all the people that were
promoting blue wave now are sort of
hedging head
hedging bets and everyone's gone 50 50.
it will all turn out
it'll all be about turnout and it will
all be about who's enthused who's scared
all of those things
um my suspicion
is that conservatives are going to do
better than most people think i think
enough of you are just sick of this and
i don't even mean this that you love the
republicans
i just think enough people have been
moved partly because of blexit partly
because of identity politics partly
because
of the cries of racism and misogyny all
that a huge amount by the way i didn't
talk about kavanaugh at all i think a
lot of people are still
really upset about that seeing the sort
of destruction
of due process i think people are really
upset about these things
and i think they want to vote out
people who hold these ideas now yes will
there be
plenty of people that are still voting
resistance that don't care about these
issues or just think differently than i
do on these issues yes
so it's almost impossible to track
however my suspicion would be
that there is good i'm not going to call
it a red wave i just you know we don't
need these these
silly labels on all these things um but
i suspect that the republicans will do
better
than than most people are saying um and
and if i'm wrong and the democrats do
really well
then i would hope i would hope
that then they would say okay we did
well
maybe we can moderate ourselves a little
bit again there's no reason to think
this there's just there just
isn't so the one way that i think we get
out of some of the craziness
is the democrats kind of get crushed the
republicans are gracious
in victory trump is gracious in victory
pretty low chance of that right and
and he governs you know a little more
from the center although i think you
could make a pretty solid argument that
he has governed in many ways from the
center and i'm talking i'm talking about
policy not rhetoric and twitter
and that from that we could get a little
bit of a return to normalcy but no i
don't expect the blue wave
i mean look nobody knows so yes it is
possible tomorrow
that the democrats will just come out in
massive numbers the lefties will come
out in massive numbers
and then what happens i mean they've
been saying it from day one from the
first day of the trump presidency we're
going to impeach trump
that would be a scary place to be in two
years of that
um so i i hope that that doesn't happen
and i and just you know
one other quick thing which is um
there's a lot of goodness out there guys
don't spend as much time on twitter it's
driving you crazy um
if if watching all these videos don't
give you anything
to take for your life that you can make
a better life with or feel more informed
then don't watch them i don't mean just
this i mean any of these things it's
like you know people always say to me
you know they'll say oh well you should
do more videos
and usually we do one or two a week and
it's like man if you give me an
hour or two hours or sometimes three
hours a week
and then maybe i'm going to assume that
you maybe listen to one of sam's shows
or maybe listen to a rogan who puts out
a couple episodes or shapiro's
putting out dailies if you listen to
enough some of that let's say you
dedicate five hours a week
to really thinking about what the issues
are that's a lot of time
that's a lot of time you do it on your
commute you do it at the gym you do it
when you're taking your dog for work
walk whatever it is
but you've devoted time to this but
there's other things that are important
in life too as jordan talks about it's
your adventure man
and figure out the best way to to live
the best life you can and the reason
that i talk about
ideas instead of people the reason i'm
not focused on
specific policies although i will gladly
tell you what i think about any policy
is because i don't think that is really
what matters i think what matters is
figuring out
how we can have conversation how we can
plow through the difficult topics how we
can agree to disagree
and what laws and what type of
government we should have that would
allow the most of us
to live exactly that way because i want
to live free so that
so i know there are people who don't
like me you don't like my views right
but i don't want i don't want them to
have power over me and that means that i
can't have power over somebody else so
somebody else might
do something with his life that i don't
like but you can't do it on my property
and you can't you can't take my stuff
anyway i do sense that that
some decency some return to uh
to intellectualism um some return to
logic i think it's all
possible there is a chance that we can
get some of this in order
um but it's on us whether you live in
the united states right now and you're
voting tomorrow or whether you live here
in sweden
or whether you live in australia that
we're going to go to in february or
wherever else it is and the fact that
these ideas are
spreading all over the place and the
fact that so many people are connecting
over them that is
seriously cool and yeah it's not it's
not going to
be what cable news talks about every
moment telling you the new racist of the
day
or what did trump tweet or the rest of
it but people are tuning out of that
stuff in droves
and you're tuning into things that i
think are way more important and way
more powerful
so on that note um reminder november
13th and 14th i'm doing stand-up in brea
and in oxnard the links
are right down below uh if you're
watching this on youtube you know our
audio podcast as i said is killing it
uh so you can always get that on spotify
or itunes or stitcher or the rest of
that
and it's ad free if you join us on
patreon it's patreon.com
reuben report uh oh and uh if you join
uh at level three or higher you get the
automatic so you get a free
vip meet and greet to any of my stand-up
shows so i've been out there meeting all
you guys it's awesome i mean i'm meeting
all these cool people all the time
people say is it tiring being on the
road like what's it like
like man it's it's awesome i meet great
people all the time
people say nice things to me it's pretty
great um
yeah so it really is anyway it's going
to be an interesting couple days in the
states i'm going to unfortunately be
sleeping when the results are coming in
but maybe i'll wake up around 4 a.m or
whatever time that is maybe 5 a.m and
kind of figure out what's going on
i'm looking forward to uh to copenhagen
tomorrow
back here in sweden next week back in uh
in helsinki
stand up and then we got a show in
hawaii right before thanksgiving and all
kinds of stuff anyway oh and i just do
want to say one other thing you know as
i've been on the road
i've been i've had to go home for little
brief moments to do the show and i did
one crazy thing which was
i went to uh to bob saget and kelly
rizzo's wedding
uh which was last sunday so i guess
that's a week ago
yesterday um and i flew home from where
the hell was i
i flew home from the uk uh
for a day for literally one day a 10
hour flight to l.a
went to the wedding and then flew to
amsterdam
and i was just like i gotta do it like
it doesn't make financial sense
certainly and i missed a couple shows
and whatever else but i was like this is
what life's all about like you don't
want to miss all the cool things that
you can
be part of um but the reason i bring
that up is because
um you know we've had to take advanced
tape a couple shows um
so like the the kyle kashuv show that we
put up a couple days ago we had to tape
you know like 10 days ago
tucker had been taped a little bit
before that janice fiamenko and i was
really concerned
that the quality of the show and the
interviews was going to suffer because
normally i would just try to do a show
and we get it out in a day or two
sometimes that day or we live stream it
but i'm really happy to see that the the
quality has not suffered i think some of
the last
few shows that we've done from coleman
hughes to tucker
uh to these last couple with kyle and
janice and everything else
um i think they've been some of our best
shows the one thing i really do miss and
i
and i appreciate your patience is i
really do miss doing the direct messages
the issue with that of course
is that the direct messages usually are
about something pretty topical and i
need to be home for that we've thought
about doing a couple of them just off my
computer like this
so maybe we'll do a little bit more so i
do uh i do look forward to getting back
to that because that's really where i
can share what i'm thinking with you
guys or maybe we'll just
do some more live streams i'd love to
know your thoughts in the comments right
down below
uh and on that note i'm gonna go hang
out with jp and a couple thousand new
uh swedish friends and then i'll maybe i
gotta go to ikea right and have some
swedish meatballs
um anyway thanks guys and uh and we'll
see what happens and
we shall continue i'll see you soon